laura tiene 48 pesos quiere guardar un
tercio de su dinero para un viaje
cuántos pesos debería de guardar
básicamente lo que nos están pidiendo es
cuál es la tercera parte de 48 pesos
encuentra una fracción equivalente a un
tercio cuyo denominador sea 48 lo que
nos piden
en esta última oración es básicamente a
ver si tenemos un tercio y lo que nos
piden es que encontremos una fracción
que sea equivalente de un tercio pero
cuyo denominador sea 48 ok lo que nos
están pidiendo básicamente es que
tenemos que poner aquí para que esta
fracción sea equivalente a esta fracción
así es que vamos a detenernos un momento
y vamos a pensar qué es lo que está
pasando en el fondo podemos poner una
caja o también podríamos haber puesto un
pay pero pues vamos a usar la caja y
esta caja como el denominador es 3 esta
caja está dividida tres pedazos iguales
en pedazos y los otros dos pedazos
tenemos que imaginar que estos pedazos
son
exactamente iguales como el numerador es
1 entonces lo que tenemos es uno solo de
estos tres pedazos
ok tenemos este pedazo nada más y si
ahora tenemos un denominador igual a 48
entonces tenemos que dividir esta caja
en 48 pedacitos iguales ahora tenemos la
fortuna de que 48 es un múltiplo de 3 o
sea 3 por 16 es igual a 48 entonces lo
que vamos a hacer es dividir cada uno de
estos pedazos en 16 partes iguales aquí
podemos dividir este tercio en dos
pedazos y luego dividirlo en cuartos y
ahora en octavos
y luego en dieciseisavos
ok acabamos de dividir este tercio en 16
pedacitos iguales y ahora dividimos este
otro pedazo en 16 partes y también este
otro pedazo en otras 16 partes iguales
así es que esta caja está dividida con
las rayas azules en 16 por tres partes
iguales o sea en 48 partes iguales
entonces si sembramos una tercera parte
de la caja lo que hacemos es ver la
división en tres partes iguales o sea la
división en amarillo y sombrear uno solo
de los pedacitos osea sombrear este
pedazo
ahora si nos fijamos en la división en
48 pedazos iguales o sea la división en
azul claro cuántos pedazos tenemos que
tomar para estar tomando todos los
pedazos sombreados por anaranjado pues
tenemos que tomar 16 de esos 48 a
bozeman entonces un tercio es igual a 16
48 a vos y bueno aquí lo vimos de una
forma muy intuitiva ya está dividimos la
caja en los 48 pedazos y todo pero hay
una forma muy automatizada para hacerlo
o sea si aquí tenemos un denominador de
3 y queremos dividir la caja en 48
pedazos entonces cada pedazo lo tuvimos
que dividir en 16 pedazos y de esa forma
obtenemos tres pedazos divididos en 16
pedazos o sea 3 por 16 48 pedazos
multiplicamos el denominador por 16 y
eso nos dio 48 y entonces si
multiplicamos el denominador por 16 lo
que tenemos que hacer es multiplicar el
numerador también por 16 y eso es lo que
nos da es 1 por 16
16 entonces lo que hay que hacer cuando
tengamos una fracción y queremos ver
cuál es la fracción equivalente a esa
fracción con cierto denominador lo que
tenemos que hacer es ver por cuánto
tenemos que multiplicar el denominador
para que nos dé el denominador deseado y
después multiplicar el numerador por ese
mismo número y listo
entonces ya encontramos cuál es la
fracción equivalente a un tercio con
denominador 48 pero se nos olvidó a ver
cuántos pesos tiene que guardar laura si
quiere guardar una tercera parte de su
dinero entonces queremos tomar la
tercera parte del dinero la tercera
parte de 48 y eso es exactamente igual a
un tercio de 48 pero saben que creo que
esta anotación es confusa pero el
momento por lo que
mejor vamos a escribirlo
así ok 48 entre 16 48 no os y aquí
tenemos un tercio y 48 enteros y ahora
sí vamos a multiplicar estas fracciones
y para multiplicar lo que tenemos que
hacer es multiplicar numerador por
numerador y eso nos da 48 y dividimos
entre el denominador por el otro
denominador que es 3 si esta operación
te confunde no te preocupes vamos a
verlo en futuros vídeos con más detalle
y 48 entre 3 nosotros sabemos que es
igual a 16 entonces una tercera parte de
48 es 16 así es que laura tiene que
guardar 16 pesos para su viaje y un
tercio es igual a 16 48 a vos bueno
espero que todo se haya entendido muy
bien